BACK.
>> WE’VE GOT ONE DOWN HERE WE’VE
GOT ONE DOWN.
>> Laura: IT’S JUST
OUTRAGEOUS.
JOINING ME NOW IS JULIO ROSOFF,
TownHall.com SENIOR WRITER ON
THE GROUND IN LOUISVILLE AND
ASKED WHEN THESE SHOTS RANG
OUT.
JULIO, WE ARE WAITING FOR AN
UPDATE FROM THE POLICE.
HAPPENING ANY MINUTE.
DESCRIBE WHAT YOU SAW AND HEARD
TONIGHT.
>> THAT CROWTHER WAS MERGING THE
STREET STREET, THEY CAME OUT OF
THE PARK AREA IN FRONT OF THE
HALL OF JUSTICE THEY’VE BEEN
GATHERING THERE.
AS THEY WERE MARCHING FROM THE
BARRICADED ZONE, THEY WERE
PEOPLE BREAKING OFF AND SMASHING
UNCOVERED WINDOWS AND SETTING
FIRES.
THEY WERE MARCHING IN THE STREET
TOWARDS THE POLICE OFFICERS.
THE OFFICERS FIRED FLASH BANGS
IN THE AIR OVER THE CROWD.
A FEW SECONDS LATER, THAT’S WHEN
WE STARTED TO HEAR GUNSHOTS.
PEOPLE STARTED TO SCATTER.
THE VIDEO THAT I POSTED, YOU CAN
SEE ME TRYING TO RUN AND GET OUT
OF THE WAY BECAUSE A FEW SECONDS
AFTER THE SHOOTING CAN BE HEARD,
POLICE STARTED TO SWARM THE
AREA.
LIKE I SAID, PEOPLE STARTED TO
SCATTER.
TRYING TO GET OUT OF THE WAY AND
AVOID ANY MORE POTENTIAL
GUNSHOTS.
>> Laura: JULIO, THE
AUTHORITIES AND SHOPKEEPERS,
BUSINESSES, PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THEY
HAVE BEEN BOARDED UP FOR WEEKS
AND WEEKS.
THEY HAVE BEEN PREPARING FOR
THIS IMMEDIATE VICINITY FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL DAYS.
THERE’S BEEN AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF CHATTER ABOUT THIS.
YET YOU CAN SEE IN A SITUATION
LIKE THIS, THERE’S ONLY SO MUCH
THE POLICE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO.
THIS "PROTEST" THAT IS JUST
VIOLENCE AND MAYHEM SPREADING
AROUND SUCH A WIDE ARRAY OF
STREETS AND BLOCKS AND ENCLOSED
AREAS.
SOONLY SO MUCH THE POLICE CAN
CONTROL.
>> EARLIER TODAY, MARCHING IN
THE STREETS.
THIS WAS AFTER THE GRAND JURY
DECISION HAVE BEEN MADE.
AGAIN, THEY WERE MARCHING IN THE
STREETS.
WINDOWS AND BUSINESSES NOT
COVERED WERE BEING TARGETED.
THEY WERE EVENTUALLY STOPPED BUT
THEY WERE STOPPED ABOUT 3 MILES
AFTER THEY WERE IN THE JEFFERSON
SQUARE PARK AREA.
THERE WAS ABOUT 3 MILES OF
PROPERTY THAT COULD POSITIONALLY
HAVE BEEN DAMAGED BY SOME OF THE
CROWD BEFORE THEY WERE PUT A
STOP TO AND PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED.
>> Laura: SOME OF THE PRINT
NEWS REPORTS FROM THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF THE GRAND JURY’S
DECISION WERE JUST ANGER.
PEOPLE WERE IN DISBELIEF.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON’T UNDERSTAND
THE GRAND JURY SYSTEM, HOW IT
WORKS, THE EVIDENCE PRESENTED
AND SO FORTH.
I GET THAT.
OTHERS WERE SAYING, ACCORDING TO
THE NEWS REPORTS, BURN THE YOU
KNOW WHAT DOWN.
THAT WAS REPEATED AND REPEATED
AND REPEATED.
BURN IT DOWN.
THE CITY IS GOING TO PAY.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING LIKE
THAT?
>> YES.
PEOPLE WERE VERY UPSET AT HOW
LOW THE BAIL WAS SET FOR THE
OFFICER CHARGED.
THEY WERE UPSET THAT ONLY ONE
OFFICER WAS CHARGED OUT OF THE
THREE.
IN FACT I GOT VIDEO.
THIS WAS EARLY ON TODAY.
SOMEONE SHOUTED IN OFFICERS, ALL
Y’ALL GET READY TO EFFINGER DIE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THREAT HAS
KIND OF COME TO FRUITION.
WE ARE STILL WAITING TO HEAR AN
UPDATE.
WE ARE OUTSIDE THE HOSPITAL
WHERE THEY ARE BEING TREATED AND
WE ARE WAITING FOR THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> Laura: JULIO.